at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask you a personal
question I must - any organism living
facility
this episode is brought to you by Inc
tel and I've used them personally ever
since I wrote the 4-hour workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life I use that in investing
as well the second how can I spend a
little money or moderate money to save
significant time Intel is one of those
investments they're a turnkey solution
for all of your imaginable customer care
needs
I used Intel during the launch of the
4-hour body which was very very involved
and they provided 24/7 customer service
for my landrush campaign because it was
critical for me to take care of every
person who purchased my books and
participated this allowed me to focus on
the things that I am better at my
strengths like the marketing plan that
we'd worked on for 6 months implementing
that Intel trains their experience
customer service reps to know your
business and your products inside and
out and make your customers raving fans
they answer more than a million customer
service requests every year and they can
do so across all platforms including
email phone social media text even chat
leaving your customers with poor service
or just mediocre service which by the
way in a competitive pool is a huge
liability long wait times or unanswered
messages carries a massive cost and risk
to your business Intel removes the
logistics and headaches of this type of
communication allowing you to focus on
your strengths and grow your business it
can be a real competitive advantage and
I see many many e-commerce companies and
tech companies thinking of customer
service as a good enough check
or an afterthought and just like Airbnb
use design in innovative ways to be a
competitor and to win you can do the
same thing with customer service so as a
listener of this podcast you can get up
to ten thousand dollars off that's a big
discount ten thousand dollars off your
startup fees and costs by visiting Inc
Telecom forward slash Tim so check it
out for more info go to Inc Telkom i NK
te l comm forward slash Tim this episode
is brought to you by helix sleep last
year I focused on dramatically improving
a few things surprise surprise
most notably the quality of my sleep
which seems to affect just about
everything this led me to revisit you
name it
my daily routine morning routine
exercise diet all the way to what I
slept on and I ended up getting all new
beds here in Austin Texas including
mattresses from helix sleep helix has
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleeper cold sleeper or you like
plush you like firm with helix there's
no more guessing or confusion just go to
helix sleep dot-com forward slash Tim
take their two minutes sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life that is their promise for couples
helix can even split the mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and fuel preferences for each side
they have a 10 year warranty and you can
test drive your mattress for 100 nights
risk-free right now helix is offering up
to one hundred and twenty-five dollars
off of all mattress orders to check it
out get up to 125 off at helix sleep
calm forward-slash Tim that's helix
sleep dot-com for slash Tim for one
hundred and twenty five dollars off your
mattress order take a look
helix sleep calm forward slash Tim
well hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show or it is my job
to interview world-class performers to
tease out the habits routines thinking
frameworks life lessons favorite books
etc that you can apply and test for
yourself this episode features someone
who is very very well-known in the world
of investing but studying what he says
is really a study in clearer thinking
and it transcends investing in business
in so many different ways Howard s Marx
is co chairman and co-founder of Oaktree
Capital Management a leading investment
manager with more than a 120 billion
dollars in assets he is the author of
the new book mastering the market cycle
subtitle getting the odds on your side
and his previous book on investing the
most important thing subtitle uncommon
sense for the thoughtful investor was a
critically acclaimed bestseller to give
you an idea of who reads his memos in
his writing Warren Buffett has written
of Howard quote when I see memos from
Howard Marks in my mail there the first
thing I open and read I always learn
something and quote I'm going to keep
this short because it covers a lot of
ground we talk about the three stages of
a bull market newsletters he reads
thoughts on Bitcoin and crypto his
thoughts on understanding market cycles
for making better decisions how his firm
was poised to capitalize on the bubble
in 2008 and put massive amounts of
capital to work and more and more and
more and more we really cover a lot of
ground and I had a lot of fun so without
further ado they've already said that
here is Howard Marx
Howard welcome to the show thank you Jim
I've been looking forward to being here
I am thrilled to be sitting here with
you because I have so many fans of your
work and thinking in my friend circles
that's great to hear when I went out to
a handful to ask for potential topics or
questions they were very very
forthcoming but what I thought I would
do in this particular episode I've never
done in a podcast episode before which
is to start with a poem this is always
risky risky business but this was
suggested by a friend and he said I
would use an AE Housman poem this
captures effectively the I think that
what he views as as as the spirit of
much of your writing and you can agree
or disagree here we go I to my perils of
cheat and charmer come clad in armor by
stars benign hope lies to mortals and
most believed her but man's deceiver was
never mine the thoughts of others were
light and fleeting of lovers meeting or
luck or fame mine were of trouble and
mine were steady so I was ready when
trouble came and that is a Shropshire
lad the name of the poem and I thought
that we could certainly talk about that
specifically but in the course of doing
research for this conversation I
discovered that you had studied not only
finance and what you might look at as
vocational subjects when you are an
undergrad but also it seems like
Japanese and that there was this concept
of Mucho that popped up when I was doing
my reading would you mind describing
that time and that concept well I went
to Wharton at a and enlightened time
when you were required to have a non
business minor and then a semester of
the literature of a foreign country in
English I never learned Japanese but I
started off for some reason which I it's
interesting that I have no recollection
of what motivated me but I decided not
French literature or English but
Japanese literature it must have been
the exotic ISM and I liked it so much
that I turned Japanese studies into my
minor and took 15 credits at the
graduate level
and that's what turned me from a from an
indifferent teenager into a into a
student really but the professor for
most of those courses a guy named a Dale
Saunders was an inspirational speaker
and Oxford Don and this theat and so I
took this course in a Japanese
philosophy and we came across mojo mojo
literally means the turning of the wheel
of the law in other words the operation
of life and the the the essence is
impermanence and because the wheel does
turn and and also the the
unpredictability of the future and these
were really formative for me and they
have unconsciously informed everything
I've done and I think that personally
that in the investment business and also
in life you are better off if you
realize number one that if life is
always going to change on you and there
will always be new things coming down
the pike and you can't control it and
what we have to do is live with it in
the course of the reading I've done prep
for this which is not only the the new
book but also many of your letters which
I'd already been a fan of but went back
to revisit I came a grant across many
people who had tried to select favorite
quotes and one that came up a lot so you
could certainly correct this is not
accurate is something along the lines of
you can't you can't predict you can
prepare and that leads me to 2008 and
we're going to bounce around
chronologically quite a lot I suspect
but during the 2008 bubble which of
course was a time in which many
investors were pulling out of the market
oak tree did exactly the opposite and
you put more than a half a billion
dollars a week to work over 15
why did you do that were you predicting
were you prepared what led to that type
of decision sure well you mentioned the
the memos I've been writing the memo
since 1990 and I wrote one about 20
years ago late 90s called you can't
predict you can't prepare I stole the
tagline from an ad from Northwestern
Mutual Life Insurance but I think that's
true of life now it sounds like an
oxymoron because how can you prepare if
you can't predict but the answer is we
never know what's going to happen but we
can consider the likely scenarios and
prepare for some of them you can't I
definition prepare for every
eventualities
but I say that we did have a sense my
partner Bruce Cara and I had a sense in
a five and six that the world wasn't
running right and the main thing that
made us conclude that was the crappy
deals that were getting done and he and
I would spend the day walking into each
other's office saying look at this piece
of crap that got issued yesterday
there's something wrong a deal like this
should not be doable the fact that
investors are buying this tells me that
they're not being skeptical they're not
being demanding they're not applying
standards and you know Buffett has a
saying the less prudence with which
others conduct their affairs the greater
the prudence with which we must conduct
our own affairs and it's absolutely true
and so we know that the market was
dangerous because of the behavior of
others now you can't so we were prepared
we we sold a lot of assets we liquidated
large funds we replaced them with small
funds we became very selective in our
buying we raised
a very large fund for investment if a
crisis bursting would come into being
was this for a distress debt for
distress debt now the interesting thing
though so you can't prepare you can't
predict the thing that caused the bubble
to burst was the unsubstantial 'ti of
mortgage-backed securities and
especially subprime if you read the
memos you won't find a word about it we
didn't predict that we didn't even know
about it
it was occurring in an in an extrude
corner of the securities market most of
us didn't know about it but it is what
what brought the house down and we had
no idea but we were prepared because we
knew simply that we were on dangerous
ground and that required cautious
preparation
let me ask and I may embarrass myself
with questions that display my ignorance
about many topics in this interview but
when you raised money for a district
that fund did you emphasize to the LPS
or whoever gave you those funds that you
had a specific timeline in mind for
deploying those funds or did you
emphasize the importance of patience
with those people that you'd be looking
for indicators and that they needed to
look at it as a long-term investment
how did you manage the question of when
from those people
the question of when is is one of the
hardest ones in our business and I
always say that we may have an idea of
what's going to happen but we never know
when it's going to happen you can't call
these things as one of my partner says
if you name a price don't name a date
and if you name a date don't name a
price and then you can't be wrong but we
never did name a date we probably I
can't even remember we probably had a
limit in other words if we hadn't
deployed it with the next year's then it
got canceled the commitments but I think
there was an understanding that we
thought it was coming within the next
one two three years something like that
now the the subtitle of this new book of
course the title mastering mark sites
subtitle getting the odds on your side
why this book and and how does one and
this is of course something we could we
could discuss for many many hours on end
but why this book and how does someone
in this context get the odds on their
side so I started writing the memos in
1990 I wrote them for 20 years I always
concluded that I would write a book and
pull them together into a philosophy
when I retired and then I got a letter
from Warren Buffett in 2010 saying if
you'll write a book I'll give you a
blurb for the jacket so that was enough
to get me off my ass and get me to do it
in real time I wrote a book called the
most important thing because I found
myself sitting in clients offices saying
the most important thing is buying cheap
and then ten minutes later I would say
the most important thing is not losing
money and then ten minutes later I would
say that the most important thing is
contrarian behavior so I wrote a book
called the most important thing which
has 21 chapters and each one starts off
the title is the most important thing is
and then it's a different thing one of
those most important things is knowing
where we stand in the cycle and as I say
I don't believe in forecasts I always
say we never know where we're going but
we sure as hell order know where we are
I mean I can't tell you what's going to
happen tomorrow but I should be able to
assess the current environment and
that's the kind of thinking that helped
us prepare for the for the crisis I
think that the two most important things
are where we stand in the cycle and the
broad subject of risk and in fact where
we stand in the cycle is the primary
determinants of risk so I think that
this is really an important topic and it
can really help you do better
getting the odds on your side what that
means is we don't know what's going to
happen nobody can tell you but there are
time
when the future is the outlook is better
and there are times when it's worse and
it's largely determined by where we
stand in the cycle when we are low in
the cycle that is to say we're coming
off a bust the economy is starting to
warm up
investors are just barely starting to
switch from pessimism to optimism and
and prices are starting to rise clearly
the odds are in your favor the outlook
is better it doesn't mean you're going
to make money but the chances are good
on the other hand when the cycle has
gone on the up cycle has gone on for a
long time when it when when valuations
are high when optimism is rampant when
everybody thinks everything's going to
get better forever when the economy's
been moving ahead for 10 years and it
looks like it's never going to stop then
usually the enthusiasm has carried the
prices to such a high level that the
odds are against you and just knowing
that is is a huge advantage in investing
you should know that when the when we're
low in the up cycle that's a time to be
aggressive and put a lot of money to
work and buy more aggressive things and
when we when the cycle has gone on for a
long time and we're elevated that's the
time to take some money off the table
and behave more cautiously question
about 2008 or you could pick another
period a bus cycle that you're familiar
with whether from first-hand experience
or from research that you've done you
raise these funds and I want to revisit
the question of when and from personal
standpoint and I'll admit it very freely
I think I've had a very fear-based
mentality when it comes to public
markets I've done reasonably well in
privately held technology startups
because I've lived in the middle of the
switch box in San Francisco and that's
the only thing I paid attention to and
it protected me in a way from my lesser
behaviors because I wasn't allowed to
sell but in the public markets I've
almost always held on to cash waiting
for some cataclysmic event but then lost
my nerve in some fashion
I'd be I'd love to hear and maybe the
catching falling knives is a way to
segue into this I don't know that I
found that very very interesting to read
about but how do you think about sitting
on a position like that and timing what
what what determines the go command for
deploying you have really touched on an
extremely important topic most of us
have an inherent bias most of us are
essentially cautious or essentially
aggressive probably more people are
essentially cautious than aggressive so
one of the most important things is to
assess ourselves understand our biases
and try to overcome them now the the Tim
Ferriss that I heard you described I
take that to mean that maybe you were
lucky or smart enough to turn cautious
leading up to the bubble the markets
fell apart you're sitting on cash you
patted yourself on the back for being so
smart as to not get caught and you're
watched what you didn't do is you didn't
turn aggressive at the bottom that's
right and it's common not to do so it's
common to as you say for people to say
I'm not going to jump in while this
thing's collapsing down I'm going to
wait till the dust has settled and the
future is clear I'm not going to try to
catch a falling knife but it is when the
knives are falling that the people are
most terrified that the best bargains
are available so if you wait until the
dust settles the bargains are gone and
that's what happened at the end of a
eight you mentioned that we in distress
debt we put five hundred million a week
to work in the last 15 weeks following
the bankruptcy of Lehman Brothers and
across the firm something like 650
million a week for 15 weeks that's 10
billion dollars at and but the key is it
was at a time when essentially nobody
else would you get great bargains by the
time the
end of a a trolled around the hedge
funds that we're getting withdrawals had
either satisfied their withdrawals or
gated and when it's gated mean told
clients they couldn't have their money
back for a while gotcha
and so the the selling abated a few
people saw that that the great values
and with this with the selling and thus
the fear having reduced they were able
to come forward prices started to move
up then it's too late because if you're
trying to buy in a falling market you
can buy all you want at successively
lower prices but if you're trying to buy
large amounts in a rising market your
own buying puts the price up you're your
own worst enemy you can't get much at
low prices so you know one of the keys
to successful investing is to either be
unemotional or at minimum act like you
are you know the great investors I know
are behaved in an unemotional fashion
you know Warren Buffett couldn't care
less David Tepper couldn't care less and
and and so forth my own partner Bruce
Carr's very very very stalwart but part
of it is that we support each other at
the bottom it's not easy you know and
and I say in the book that I recount
some of the things we've done right with
regard to cycle extremes but I
absolutely don't want to give the
impression that it's easy it's
terrifying
others are terrified that's why they're
selling that's why they're saying I
don't care what the price is just get me
out that's what that's when you want to
buy but the things that terrify them
into selling will also terrify you you
have to overcome it how much of that
stoic resilience or stoic composure is
nature versus nurture born versus
trained in from what you've observed and
experienced and and if if a portion of
it is trained how how would you suggest
to someone that they develop that
ability I don't want to answer
categorically I think it's a help a lot
easier if you born them yeah you know or
to teach yourself to be unemotional is
to is to count their human nature and by
definition it can't be easy this is
other than as to you know where are we
in the cycle and what's going to happen
in the sick coming six months this is
probably the question I get the most
often hmm how can you teach yourself to
be unemotional to be contrarian to be a
second level thinker and there is no
easy answer in the first book on the
subject of what I call second level
thinking I say invest ball they say you
can't coach height all the coaching in
the world will not yet make your team
taller so I don't know frankly whether
you can whether people can teach
themselves to be unemotional but clearly
if you are as emotional as others you
will probably succumb to the same errors
so let's I think we can I'd love to back
into this type of not psychological
profiling but an examination of of this
type of resilience
maybe indirectly maybe it'll come up
maybe at one but and I might get the the
total duration incorrect but you
mentioned a name Bruce Karsch that I'd
love to to bring up yet again and he
made me make him up repeatedly 23 year
partnership is that right or 20-plus
year 31 31
I was oak tree is 23 years I got we
worked together for eight years before
its prior to that alright so if you were
trying to hire a it's a 25 year old
version of Bruce what would you be
looking for well I'll tell you what he
is let's let's do that he's super smart
that goes without saying he is highly
competitive you know he's a chess player
and and most of the people that again
that I know who are good investors are
our games players either backgammon or
or chess or something like that
we are an inherently competitive he's
also a very analytical and he's kind of
a grinder and I would describe myself as
being intuitive and and a quick decider
thinking slow and fast
Kahneman I'm a fast thinker you tell me
a problem I tell you my answer in short
order and I'm done with it
for the most part Bruce will think about
it longer come to his conclusion and
then he'll come back the next day and
say you know I was thinking about it
last night I don't think that's right
and here's why or I don't think you were
right and here's why and he'll he'll
grind on it for hours and days I think
this is part of the secret to our
success again something I once wrote on
the subject of a good partnership I said
I said shared values and complementary
skills if you have a partner who has
different values than you do for example
Bob wants to make the most money
possible and Edie wants to operate with
integrity those are largely
contradictory so I think it's very
important to share values but I also
think it's it's important to not be the
same person a copy of yourself if you're
if it's a copy of himself you don't need
it
it the person should bring skills that
you don't bring and maybe operate in
ways you don't and I think it's it's
probably helpful that um intuitive and
he's analytical I've heard well heard
that's nothing right not the right verb
I've read I believe was Buffett who said
that Charlie Munger has the something
along lines of the best 60 second mind
he's ever encountered it sounds like you
also have a very highly developed fast
thinking capacity is how is it similar
or different from Charlie Munger's 60
second well it first of all it's
daunting
paracin I would never put myself in the
category with Charlie he's he's
brilliant and and one of the best
thinkers there is but you know I mean
the main thing is that he has read more
broadly he's had he's had another 22
years to read further and he was
probably always a broader reader than I
was and so it's it's his ability to call
on these references you know it's in a
way it's kind of silly to think we have
to endure that we can reinvent all the
wisdom in the world it's great to borrow
from others and and and Charlie does
that broadly and I try to do it but he
just knows more I think well will almost
certainly come back to Warren and
Charlie more in this conversation but I
want to return to to Bruce because you
mentioned the complementary skill sets
and you've you've written about him of
course quite a bit mentioned him quite a
bit and I want to pull up quickly just a
few lines in the new book so Bruce and I
have exchanged ideas and backed each
other up almost daily over that period
this is preceding text and my
give-and-take with him especially in the
most difficult of times has played a
particularly indispensable part in the
development of the approaches to cycles
on which this book is based could you
share an example of a back and forth or
disagreement during a difficult time or
with a particular decision is that
possible just so that we have a
real-world example of the interplay
between the two of you we we normally
don't debate individual investments
because he operates more at that level
and I operate more at the big picture
level it within oak tree but I mean I
think a good example is in the period we
just we've been talking about a couple
of times now we mentioned the last 15
weeks of oh eight you know it was really
a very tough period because Lehman
Brothers had gone bankrupt and and Bear
Stearns had disappeared and Merrill
Lynch had been absorbed by Bank of
America and Washington Mutual and
Wachovia Bank and you know and it looked
like falling dominoes and
you know people were talking about the
fact that Morgan Stanley was next and
Goldman was right behind that and so you
just had to conclude that the world that
the financial world was either gonna end
or it wasn't
you couldn't analyze it you couldn't
prove anything about the future and and
and and so it required a and almost
gamesman like approach to whether you
buy or not and you know we would talk
about that in that sense and we were
both very comfortable talking about it
in that sense and what we concluded was
that if the world ended it didn't matter
what we did but if the world didn't end
and we hadn't bought we hadn't done our
job so up and do your job now the
great thing is that half the day's Bruce
would come to me because he would be
lying in bed at night thinking about
this stuff and he would come to me and
he would say you know what I think we're
going too fast I think we should slow
down and half the days he would say I
think we're going too slow and you know
so I would play devil's advocate and and
support his decision but but try to show
him the other side and and he would do
that with me and that's why we got it
done but I as I say in the in the
introductions of the book from which you
read I think that I don't think either
of us could have done as good a job
alone I think that the devil's advocacy
and but in a supportive way really held
the key I wrote in one of my memos I I
wrote about a reporter and he he he
called me up a few days after the
bankruptcy of Lehman and he said what
are you doing I said we're buying he
said you are like it was the craziest
thing he ever heard and you know my
reaction was if we're not buying that
when we would but you know it's been a
great partnership as you say 31 years
never an argument never an are you never
an argument I mean it
the intellectual disagreements but never
an emotional argument and never and the
key is respect
even when we disagree we respect and the
great thing about that is you sit down
you disagree you maybe you don't come to
a conclusion and then you go back to
your corners and he says well you know
what maybe how it's right and I say
maybe Bruce is right and then you can
have a productive discussion if if you
if your reaction is that
then you can't benefit from what he has
to say for for people who are hoping to
exhibit that type of poise and respect
for someone else
are there any tactical recommendations
you might have and the reason I ask that
is I no longer live in Silicon Valley
but as our 17 years and you see
co-founder splits all the time some of
them go the distance but a lot of them
end up fatalities and you can almost see
the writing on the wall when the respect
goes out the window and it's just a
matter of time for a lot of these guys
four four people who are in partnership
let's just for the time being assume
it's in a business capacity or an
investing capacity what are some of the
tools of the trade so that it doesn't
escalate do you walk out of the room if
you're starting to get heated there or
do you avoid in some systems way given
policies of the firm any types of sort
of mission-critical single decisions
from becoming an object of argument if
that makes any sense because when the
stakes are high what are some some
recommendations you would have when
things when perhaps emotions are
starting to escalate well the only issue
I would take Tim is you started with
assume you're in partnership I think you
have to start sooner okay who do you get
in partnership with and you know you
have to you have to share values and you
shouldn't be partners with somebody
you're not gonna like enjoy spending
time with and be able to work with
constructively when the stuff hits the
fan that's really the key so I mean I
believe that
that most solving most personnel or
managerial problems start at the
beginning with the hiring decision or
the combination decision so so you know
just don't get into business with
somebody you're not gonna be able to
live with it's kind of like a marriage
do you stress test their ability to
handle potential high-stress situations
in some real or simulated fashion do you
look back at in say hiring decision do
you look back at their history and
reference checks to assess that how do
you assess whether someone is going to
keep their cool or not
well we don't do simulations or war
games like that but we do you know I
mean that's an important part of
reference checking you have to you have
to look beyond whether it's the person
is smart and whether the person's the
moneymaker you know we have a no
rule at oaktree and I think
that saves solves a lot of problems and
you know there are lots of people in the
world who can make a lot of money
but you you may not want to be in
business with them and it may not be
viable long term now it's it's hard to
absolutely follow that rule because
really smart money makers are very
tempting but I think it's I think it's
really important but but then you know
once once you are in business together
and you have the inevitable disagreement
I think one of the most important things
is to number one acknowledge the limits
on what you know if you if you go in
with some humility then you're unlikely
to have a fight to the death that is to
the death of your partnership over an
issue and and it's it's you know it's
great to say I mean people should wake
up in the morning and start the day by
practicing I don't know I don't know
it's a great thing to say and not enough
people say it and and the the the the
flipside of I don't know is what I said
it before about our discussions maybe
he's right you know
and so I think that's important humility
number two again control of emotion
don't get into fights just to show who's
who's more manly or you know or equate
winning the argument with success
because if you're if you're in a
business situation and you're fighting
for something that ultimately proves out
to be a mistake your success in winning
the argument will lead to a failure so
don't confuse winning the argument with
coming to the best decision and you know
again try to limit the testosterone I
think that really gets in the way one
one of the many things that I really
enjoy about your writing is that it
serves for me at least as a reflection
on clear thinking that transcends
investing I mean it applies to so many
if not all areas of life at least those
governed by anything in the prefrontal
cortex and one that caught my eye when I
was when I was reading just page 15 in
the new book is the following and I just
like to read it's not very long in
addition to an opinion regarding what's
going to happen people should have a
view on the likelihood that their
opinion will prove correct some events
can be predicted with substantial
confidence example given will a given
investment in great bond pay the
interested promises some are uncertain
example will Amazon still be the leader
in online retailing in 10 years and some
are entirely unpredictable example will
the stock market go up or down next
month it's my point here that not all
predictions should be treated as equally
likely to be correct and thus they
shouldn't be relied on equally I don't
think most people are as aware of this
as they should be
could you expand on this a bit if that's
possible maybe give some examples of how
you or other people you respect use that
type of heuristic when making decisions
are just I suppose reflecting reality
and their own minds are perceiving
things sure you know we all have
opinions
and we hold our opinions because we
believe in them nobody ever says you
know my opinion is X and I think I'm
wrong we all think that our opinions are
correct but and and and again the world
becomes a better place an easier place
to navigate if we admit that even though
there are opinions that they may be
wrong and you know how does an investor
like me deal with the fact that he
doesn't believe in future predictions
and and and the answer is I say and I
have opinions on all the subjects but I
say it's one thing to have an opinion
and there's a it's another to believe
and act as if it's right and if you just
say maybe I'm wrong if the world gets
easier in my opinion easier to succeed
less less easy to to navigate day to day
you know and and a big theme of the book
is that we have to view the future not
as an event which is predetermined and
predictable or you know determined
already but as a range of possibilities
as a probability distribution and you
know I went to the World's Fair in
Flushing in 1964 I think it was and I
stood before an exhibit that IBM had and
it was you know typical of technology 50
odd years ago it was the most implicitly
you could imagine they had they had a
slot at the top and a bunch of balls and
the balls came through the slot and then
there were a bunch of pegs in a grid and
when the balls hit the pegs they started
to diffuse and by the time they get to
the bottom they were in a bell-shaped
distribution and I think that was
probably my first exposure to a
distribution but it's beautiful and
that's how life is the future is a
distribution of possibilities and if
we're really smart we know what the
district
fusion what the possibilities are and we
may have an idea of which are more
likely and less likely but we still
don't know what's going to happen and
and and I think we have to behave that
way now some things we know more some
things we know less we shouldn't get
confused but the most important single
thing is to not have the same degree of
conviction about all of our opinions if
you do you apply it by episode one to
ten numerical value is it more of a
light medium strong how do you think
about that yourself yeah well I think
it's certainly not you know I'm not a
for the most part a quantifier if you
read the book you I would hope you would
be struck by how few numbers there are
in it and you know one of the great
quotes which has broadly attributed to
Einstein I don't think it was Einstein
is that not everything that can be
counted counts and not everything that
counts can be counted so the most
important insights to life are non
quantitative but I try to be conscious
of when I have an opinion of how likely
it is to be correct and I try really
hard not to always assume that I'm right
by the way let me add one thing
Henry Kaufman who was the chief
economist of Salomon Brothers in the 70s
at a time when America was Riven with
hyperinflations 15 16 17 percent a year
nobody could figure out how to stop it
and and the world was really a very
difficult place to live at Kaufmann
there was two guys Kaufman and now Wall
gional our first Boston they were called
dr. gloom and dr. doom but and and but
but Kaufman said two kinds of people
lose a lot of money the people who know
nothing and the people who know
everything and it's very few of us know
nothing but it's really important to
assume to not assume we know everything
is there any reading you've done or
maybe it's just real life experience in
the trenches of doing this day
but if for people who want to develop
that I saw that your seems like a reader
or fan of some of what nos and Talib has
put out and he talks about
epistemological arrogance quite a bit
it's thinking that we are believing we
know it all or more than we we actually
know how would you suggest or there any
resources letters books memos talks that
you might recommend to people who want
to really cultivate that awareness of
limited knowledge well when you started
to ask that question I I did
fast-forward to NASA Nicholas celeb and
his book fooled by randomness I think
it's a really important book in terms of
its ideas and it's a it's really about
how much randomness there is in our
world now it's primarily about investing
not the general world but the world of
investing and you know his example is
that if you're a dentist he picks on the
dentist a lot in the book but it but if
you're a dentist picks on economists -
yes and you always fill a tooth the same
way you always get a successful filling
whereas in the investment business
there's nothing that you can do that if
you do it the same every time you're
going to get a successful outcome
because of the change ability and
randomness in the world and and this is
extremely important and you know we have
to think about the world as a
probability distribution when we you
know one of the things that interests me
most is when you look at history you say
well I don't know so much about the
future but the history that's that's
done that's settled we know what happens
we know what the truth was
but celeb uses a concept called
alternative histories the other things
that reasonably probably could have
happened but didn't and so when you look
at a historical event you have to say
was it was that outcome inevitable in
case it demonstrates a truth or was it
subject to randomness and could other
things have happened just as well you
know I wrote a memo in in a memo around
oh six I talked about the Rose Bowl game
between USC and University of Texas and
USC was highly touted as the best team
in the history of foot college football
and and it I would go through all of it
I hope readers will take a look at it
but in the end they lost on one play and
so nobody talked about him as being the
best football team in history my point
was and I wrote I entitled this section
what's real maybe they were the best
team in history and maybe the fact that
they didn't weren't successful on that
one play that the whole game thought
maybe it was because the wind was
blowing left to right rather than right
to left at that moment and so we should
not be too firm in our conclusions it's
I guess the the recurrent theme is that
is a lack of certainty but I I really
would push people to fooled by
randomness there's a little book by John
Kenneth Galbraith called the short
history of financial euphoria and a
great quote he said we have two kinds of
forecasters the ones who don't know and
the ones who don't know they don't know
and and that has been very inspirational
for me I was I don't think this was
attributed to you but I came across it
in looking at some highlights of your
memos in prep for this conversation and
I don't think it's tributed to you but
someone said dumb money can become smart
money if it accepts its limitations I
don't know if you would agree with that
but it's it's stuck with me as maybe not
necessarily forecasters but at least
people who cultivate becoming aware of
what they don't know sure well I think
first of all knowing what you don't know
is one of the keys to success in
anything you know Dirty Harry said a man
should know his limitations I wouldn't
say it's not my quote I wouldn't
necessarily say that dumb money can be
smart money but but I would say that one
of the ways to avoid being dumb money is
to not act as if you know things you
don't know maybe by the time I get done
giving the quote I'll be ever able to
remember who said it but somebody very
wise said Mark Twain that's it
it's not what you don't know that gets
you into trouble it's what you know for
certain that just ain't true that is so
important there's nothing more dangerous
in life than being sure you know
something that you don't know if you are
if you have excess certitude you will do
things boldly
in dangerous ways and too dangerous
extents that have the ability to get you
into trouble get you killed but a
sentence that starts off with I'm not
sure but is unlikely to lead to fatal
action the distinction to me is so clear
and and so unarguable that I I think
this is one of the most important things
for life know your limitations you
mentioned a little bit earlier how you
could potentially say to yourself in the
morning I don't know I don't know maybe
he or she is right maybe he or she is
right
it makes me think of some of these
memento mori type quotes that maybe may
be apocryphal from ancient Rome or
they'd have leave you to someone behind
the emperor when he's being paraded
through the streets and you're just a
man you were just a man something like
that I know this is seemingly maybe not
on the same topic but nonetheless I want
to ask about it do you have any
particular routines or habits in the
first say hour or two of your day
whether it's now or whether you were
kind of if you can if they're a
particularly productive period in your
professional life where you feel like
those routines or habits in the morning
we're important does anything come to
mind I don't have stylized
routines I I mean I would just say that
my life is is pretty calm and I try to
keep it that way
and what would be a symptom of it not be
come and how would you respond to that
well watching too much political TV and
getting exercised about what you see on
TV would be a good example I mean that's
that's negative energy that's not going
to contribute to your effectiveness in
the day now my the fact that I don't get
exercised about what I see on the news
shows is not purposeful so up to this
point we've talked a fair amount about
the importance of avoiding hubris of
understanding your limitations the
incompleteness of your knowledge how do
you balance that with perhaps knowing
your strengths well enough or having
conviction in evidence to the extent
that you can then take action sure well
that's a great question to him and
clearly it's essential to balance you
don't want to be the person who thinks
he knows everything but you can't be
very successful in life and especially
not at investing if you think you're the
person who knows nothing there is no
magic in it there is no rule no method
it's just the an awareness but we we
have to feel we know enough to take
action now most successful people most
smart people have don't have a problem
in that area they have a history of
having their ideas validated for the
most part but I think it's it's it's I
mean it is one of the great conundrums
which is unanswerable methodologically
you know you buy a stock at a tea it
falls to 60 you say well I think it's
cheaper now I like it more I'm gonna buy
more you buy more now as well as the 40
is there a point at which you say well
maybe I'm wrong and maybe the markets
right you know if you if you throw in
the towel and sell every stock you buy
when it goes down a little you can't you
can never be successful but if you
ignored the possibility that you're
wrong you can never be successful and
you have to strike a balance so
when you buy a stock and it goes down a
little you take another look at your
analysis is there anything you missed
the did your analysis hold water and and
so forth maybe you talked to some people
that you respect to get their opinions
but you know again if you're if you're
too sure you're in trouble and if you're
too unsure you're in trouble you have to
strike a balance if we come back to the
hypothetical example you gave someone
buying at 60 it drops to 40 drop to 30
drops to 20 to avoid being in that
position where you are offering yourself
the option of buying or selling at each
of those check-in points what are you
deciding in advance so that you don't
make those interim mistakes or you don't
even make those decisions or look at
them to begin with
that's not my approach or Oaktree's
approach we don't have preset rules
everybody says well why don't you just
set a rule there are things called
stop-loss orders you why something goes
down 20% you sell it every time there is
no rule that will ever work in every
case you have a you have a rule that
goes down 20 or out so it goes down 21
you sell then it goes up a hundred you
know or it goes down 10 you don't sell
and it never goes up again there there
can't be a rule that always works when
they just before the publication of my
other book I had lunch with Charlie
Munger and and at the end of the lunch
when I got up to go he said now just
remember none of this is meant to be
easy anybody who thinks it's easy is
stupid these things cannot be reduced to
a rule the market operates so as to
confound rule makers you know it it and
I wrote a memo five years ago called
it's not easy it all comes down to
judgment we have to have if we're going
to have superior investment performance
we have to have superior judgment
and you you I mean you can work on your
processes both intellectual and
emotionally but you can't I mean
superior judgment is isn't something you
can order up and not everybody can
necessarily attain it but I mean I think
that one of the most important things is
is to dismiss the concept of a process
or a rule that always works in the
absence of superior judgment is the
judgment the the decision to take a
certain path versus another in other
words and I know I'm going to be
bastardizing this but if if if an
advantage could take the form of access
to better information better analysis of
that information making a better
decision with this with that information
that is available having the courage to
act on it and then the emotional
fortitude to either act on it or also
sit with that decision and there may be
other behavioral psychological
advantages or disadvantages I'm sure
there are when you talk about judgment
is that a particular link in that in
that chain is it I think judgement is
everything for example just to follow
your taxonomy judgment is knowing when
you have information that others don't
and if you think you know something that
others don't
it's knowing when yours is likely to be
valid and not knowing whether you're
likely to be offbeat it's understanding
how to analyze it it's judgment is is is
the reaching of conclusions based on
your analysis and judgment is all we
have to tell us when something goes
against us whether we should hang in or
give up so as I say I think it's it's
all judgement I would imagine a lot of
people read your memos and your writing
to develop in hopes of developing better
judgment and that while there there is
no one rule that will work for all
circumstances all cases there may be
certain
questions or tools that prove helpful in
a in a greater percentage of cases than
others and to that I would love to refer
to a few things that I have in front of
me one is is a letter that you sent to
me along with the book and towards the
end of the letter it's it it says I draw
my 50 years of investing experience to
provide an orientation to the usual
cycles in the economy corporate profits
the availability of credit and the
securities markets as well as some of
the less ordinary ones for example in
distressed debt investor psychology and
even in success but I think potentially
the I think potentially the most useful
chapter the most useful is the chapter
on the cycle and attitudes towards risk
how investors are thinking about risk
and behaving toward it at a point in
time might be the single most
influential determinant of markets
position in the cycle and thus the best
indicator of how we should behave with
regard to and I I read that chapter I
believe I had the right chapter and
there's there's a point in this chapter
that is that has a few lines bolded
which I really appreciate by the way and
it is if I could if I could ask only one
question regarding each investment i had
under consideration it would be simple
how much optimism is factored into the
price could you talk about this question
and perhaps give some examples of using
it or how people might use it sure you
know I started in the business and a
summer job at Citibank summer 68 fifty
years ago and the bank was an investor
in then v what was called the nifty 50
the 50 best and fastest growing
companies in America and if you bought
the stocks the year I showed up and held
them five years you've lost almost all
your money in the best companies in
America then 10 years later I switched
to the so-called junk bond business
high-yield bonds now I'm lending money
to the work companies in America and I'm
making money steadily and consistently
so clearly buying good things can't be
the secret to success in investing and
avoiding bad things it has to be the
price you pay
it's not what you buy it's what you pay
and there are there's no asset which is
so good that it can't become overpriced
this is of course something that people
have to bear in mind when they look at
the fang stocks and on the other hand
those who don't know concerning Facebook
Amazon Netflix Google and and they throw
in Alphabet too and so there is no asset
which is so good that it can't be
overpriced there are very few assets
which are so bad that they can't be
under priced and thus a bargain so what
we have to look for if we're going to be
successful investors now my school which
is called value investing it puts more
emphasis than perhaps venture capital or
growth investing which you know largely
looks for brilliant futures but the key
is paying a low price relative something
to something called intrinsic value if
you pay a high price relative to the
value you're unlikely to do well and yet
probably have to get lucky to have a
good return but if you pay a low price
relative to the intrinsic value then the
odds again like my book says are on your
side so we want low price to value how
do you get low price to value and the
answer is low optimism there are other
ways to describe it you mean looking for
low overall optimism right if if if in
short the things that everybody feels
good about are likely to be the things
that are high priced and the things that
everybody feels bad about are likely to
be low price so if you could find out
that here's here's a stock nobody thinks
this company can ever have a good day
maybe there's a chance that it will
produce some favourable surprises and
make you a lot of money if there's a if
there's a company like the nifty 50 back
in 68 everybody assumed literally Tim
nothing bad could ever happen to these
stocks then clearly there has to be so
much optimism in the price that it's
that there will never there can
ever be a favorable surprise we make
money from favorable surprises and if if
the conviction of positive conviction is
so high then clinician there can never
be a favorable surprise so I I think
that this is a number-one concept you
did you you mentioned it this I think I
think you said the word never in this
sort of hypothetical exuberant
enthusiasm what someone might say and
what what I believe you there are
certain words you dislike using well
they pay attention to when they come up
it's all part of the of this lack of
intellectual hubris right we should
never say never always has to can't you
know these these these expressions are
far too absolute to be winners in a
world beset by uncertainty and
randomness and when you when you use
those words you tend to get into big
trouble when assessing public sentiment
it could be really wide let's say anyone
participating the sp500 it could be
narrower but let's let's assume we're
looking at the the the broad the
broadest collection of market
participants at least let's just let's
just say SP 500 I was texting with a
friend of mine who's a successful
investor very different stylistically
than yourself and I asked him I said
what what would people use or what do
investing pros use or what's what do
some of them used to measure how feel
fearful or greedy and then in quotation
marks the market is are their go-to
indices or polls and he said people use
the VIX as a measure of fear VIX and
then he said some people might use
something like yield on junk bonds as a
measure in other words you low yield
equals complacent market what are let's
say it seems
difficult to keep track of the media as
a whole although certainly it becomes
obvious at some point if it's all
negative or all positive are there
particular indicators that you like to
pay attention to or your firm likes to
at least keep an eye on in the old book
there's a chapter that talks about the
importance of taking the temperature of
the market knowing where we stand and it
has a it includes with a checklist
largely tongue-in-cheek called the poor
man's guide to market assessment and
basically ask some simple questions
what's going on are if a new fund comes
out does it sell out immediately or does
a struggle if if if an investor goes to
a cocktail party yeah there you are it's
also a new book
oh it's also in the noodle it's great
yeah you know if an investor like me
goes to a cocktail party is he is he the
center of attention that everybody was
to talk to well that's probably a sign
that they're interested in the market is
too high or is he pushed into a corner
and everybody wants to talk to to the
athletes and the and the venture capital
guys and that's probably an indication
that interested my part of the market is
too low and that bargains may be
available you know and when you turn on
TV is that all they want to talk about
is the good news or the bad news and I
have some cartoons in in in the new book
old cartoons dredged up from my files
but you know it just they demonstrate
that virtually everything in the world
that in the markets is subject to either
positive or negative interpretation and
if everybody is interpreting everything
positively that tells me that the that
the spirits are too high and and perhaps
ready to be dashed and and vice versa
you know the greatest thing I was ever
taught was back around 73 74 somebody
said I'm going to tell you about the
three stages of the bull market and in
the first stage just a few in
insightful people understand that there
could be improvement and in the second
stage most people recognize that
improvement is actually taking place and
in the third stage everybody and his
brother believes that things will only
get better forever now I think this is
number one this is a very accurate
description of the world number two
clearly if you buy in the first stage
when only a few people understand the
potential for improvement you're going
to pay a low price because there isn't
much optimism in the price then as you
progress to the second and third stage
the unanticipated improvement takes
place that gives the market a favorable
surprise the stock prices or the asset
prices rise in response to those
favorable surprises and but you
eventually reach a point where the good
news convinces people that it's going to
go on forever and when everybody
believes that things will get better
forever
clearly it's likely that so much
optimism is in the stock price that it's
dangerous and unlikely to yield a profit
so I think that the three stages of the
bull market and conversely of the bear
market are really important not as a
money-making rule but as something to
bear in mind and watch out for I'm gonna
ask you a few questions that that you
may not like but that my fans will kill
me for if I don't ask so where I guess
number one is where do you think we are
at the moment and of course this has to
be time-stamped and then we're talking
in August two thousand eighteen and what
has you worried what has you optimistic
if you're optimistic about anything
sure well where are we for the last ten
years ever since the crisis people have
been asking that question in the form of
what inning are we
when they asked it in lado 8 what they
really meant was how much longer will
the pain go on now what they're asking
is how much longer will the pleasure go
on and the bull market and the economic
recovery I think we're in the eighth
inning now you don't have to timestamp
it because I've been saying this for a
while
and I'm likely to continue to do so but
about a year ago I came to realization
that that observation
even if accurate is of limited use
because unlike baseball we don't know
how many innings there are in a game
this is a big distinction in a normal
baseball game we know there are nine
innings if I say we're in the eighth and
if I say it accurately that means the
good times are about to end but in
economies and markets there is no fixed
duration so the bull market this is the
tenth year that's a long time in the
economic recovery this month we have
begun the 10th year the longest economic
recovery in recent history is 10 years
so these observations start to tell you
not that it's going to end but that they
likelihood of its continuing is
declining the odds are not on your side
when you're in the tenth year the odds
of having 10 more years of recovery
seemingly are not good we don't know if
there's some reason why there has never
been a recovery of more than 10 years
but we have to wonder if there is but on
the other hand we can't be too sure now
I believe that this economic recovery
for many years was the slowest on record
that is probably helpful because that
kept excesses from coming into existence
that have to be corrected with a with a
downturn so you asked about the good
news
the good news is that the economy is
functioning at a high level we just had
a quarter of unusually rapid growth
unemployment is declining our economy is
the envy of the world stock prices which
were very high when
measured by price earnings ratio last
year are not so expensive this year
because the earnings have been
supercharged by the tax bill the the
projected earnings of the sp500 are way
up this year 23% I think which is
unusual and higher earnings everything
else being equal means a lower price
earnings ratio so on my most measures
stocks are only slightly expensive at
this point in time so that's the good
news
the bad news is number one interest
rates are likely to increase and
interest rates increase the burden of
debt on companies and when bonds yield
more they offer more competition for
stocks clearly there are a lot of
uncertainties in the macro world in the
geopolitical world and in the political
world the the greatest of which is the
possibility of a trade war which almost
everybody thinks would be extremely
negative not only for the US and for the
people who engage in the trade war but
for everyone and I think that
interestingly what we've been talking
about is assessing the level of investor
psychology I don't believe that investor
psychology is terribly frothy the way I
put it in the past is that people are
not thinking bullish but they're acting
bullish a lot of people have moved into
higher risk investments in order to get
the returns they want because right now
safe investments Treasuries and and
high-grade bonds and cash and money
markets or for so little so people have
been forced to move out the risk curve
and take more risk and that makes the
world a riskier place for you and me I
borrowed a phrase from my late
father-in-law who said that those people
could be described as handcuffed
volunteers they're doing things not
because they want to but because they
have to but the effect on the market is
the same when people move to riskier
actions that makes the market riskier
for everyone
so if we were to consider all of that if
you had say three people come to you and
you had to you had to give them some
response because that's like a
mother-in-law people in the family so
you have to give them some kind of
response and I might be feel free to ask
some clarifying questions but let's say
someone has 100k to invest 1 million 10
million to invest so 100k 1 million and
10 million they make $100,000 a year
that is going to remain stable and
predictable it's just assumed that on
the income side they are very cautious I
think like a lot of people the loss
aversion and pain of losing $100 hurts
much more than the joy they derive from
making $100 and they have their
investable funds in this case 100k 1
million 10 million in cash or cash like
equivalents or some of these safe
vehicles currently and they say Howard I
don't know to do what are your thoughts
I think that one of the most important
things of investing is to make people
comfortable it's a mistake to sit there
and say you should do this you should do
that regardless of people's comfort
level because if you violate their
comfort level if you force them into
things that are too risky for them and
then things go bad they're unlikely to
do the right thing they're more likely
to panic and sell on the way on the lows
which is the cardinal sin of investing
so it's very important to assess
people's needs an ability to withstand
tough times clearly the person who makes
a hundred and and and has a hundred
doesn't have a big margin of safety for
tough times and and and they should
invest more conservatively the person
with ten million depending on his
psychology or her psychology probably
would be willing to stomach some losses
in the pursuit of big gains now
people always over estimate in advance
there the equanimity with which they
would greet losses you know back in
nineteen ninety seven eight-nine when
this in the stock market and the tech
stocks were rocketing along what a what
a lot of people I think said is well I
you know my 401 KS been doing so great I
wouldn't mind if I lost a third of my
money it's okay believe me when when it
when they lost a third of their money
they weren't okay but you know our
manager of my manager for the last few
years has been moved forward but with
caution and and so in varying degrees to
those three people what I would say we
are investing every day we are
endeavoring to be fully invested today
other than in funds that are strictly
designated as standby funds for the for
the crisis we are definitely taking risk
but with caution we're a cautious firm
we invest in risky asset classes
high-yield bonds distressed debt real
estate emerging market stocks and bonds
etc these are these are risky assets and
oaktree has always taken a low-risk
approach a controlled risk approach to
those asset classes so when I say with
caution I mean with more caution than
usual I think this is the time for more
caution than usual and that's what I
would tell those people but I don't so I
think that the the the outlook is not so
bad and the prices are not so high that
you have to practice maximum defensive
this and go to cash and and and suffer a
1% return on cash but I think the
outlook is not so good and prizes are
not so low but this is time for
aggressiveness and I wouldn't be
aggressive the the I think one way to
that I help myself make these decisions
and it might not be helpful to your
listeners is I recon remind myself and
others that as an investor there are
really two key risks that we face every
day now the first one is obvious and
we know that it's the risk of losing
money what's the second not so obvious a
little more subtle it's the risk of
missing opportunity and most people if
if reminded of the twin risks they would
say well I think that's right and the
truth is that I don't want to lose a lot
of money but on the other hand I don't
want to miss all the opportunities so
I'm gonna compromise I'm going to
balance the two I'm gonna do something
kind of in the middle and that makes
sense everybody you know other than
their devils and scaredy-cats everybody
should do something in the middle
exactly where in the middle is is is
debatable and should be tailored to
their own psyche and financial position
so the interesting question is okay what
about today today should you be at in in
your normal balance between the twin
risks or should it be different should
you be in a higher risk position because
so many things yields so little or
should you be in a lower risk position
because there are so many uncertainties
and I actually think the latter so fully
invested and being cautious does not
mean being in cash but everything you
want to do in the investment business
there are higher and lower risk ways to
do it and I think today is a time for
the lower risk ways so I you know this
is not the first time I've asked a
question like this but the last time I
asked the first part of that which was
making a hundred grand a year I've
someone has 100 grand grand to spend was
actually at the Berkshire Hathaway
shareholders meeting a long long time
ago and as my first and only time there
and I was so excited to be there I mean
it's Woodstock for investor nerds and it
was it was there's so much excitement
people were camped out out front to be
in line I was part of that and I asked
someone working there where the
microphone was that was hardest to get
to and then I sprinted over there and I
was able to ask Warren and Charlie this
question and of course you know them and
the responses can be very short and I
said if someone hypothetically we're
making $100,000 a year
had $100,000 to deploy in some way how
would you suggest they invest that
capital and it was along the lines I've
invested in the S&P 500 or a low-cost
index fund and the SP 500 and get back
to work and I found that very
dissatisfying but in retrospect
certainly not the worst advice that you
could give someone I'd how how do you
what do you disagree with with Warren
most on what do you guys not see eye to
eye on you know Tim there's a book out
called the Warren Buffett way and I was
asked to write the foreword for the
latest edition and I wrote something
called what wakes Warren Buffett Warren
Buffett and I listed the things that
characterized him extremely high IQ
unemotional great analysts understand
what's important looks at the things
that are important and figures out their
import ignores the things that are
unimportant and on and on like that and
the last one was the most one of the
most important he's not afraid of
getting fired he doesn't have to worry
about the the interim consequences of
error most people do and so you know
okay so you say your your advice is or
his advices invest in an index line fine
as far as it goes but how much should
the person who has a hundred thousand
put the whole hundred thousand in the
stock market right and especially should
they do it today and if they do it all
today we're confident that 20 years from
now they're going to have a lot more
money and they're going to be really
happy what about a year from now and and
not everybody is financially able to
live through a decline an emotionally
able and so as I said the first purpose
of investing especially for people who
have more money than they need to eat
should be to make you comfortable when I
started at the bank
Citibank 50 years ago they had a cartoon
on the wall
it said scared money never wins
and it's true and so everybody should
invest only up to their comfort level
and so I think I would I I certainly
agree with Warren that for most people
they can't improve on an index fund but
but that's and I'm not saying that
Warren says that everybody should put a
hundred percent of their net worth in
the index button but clearly they
shouldn't and and I was once at a at a
talk and I was preceded by by a college
professor I won't identify him Boren
always says praised by name criticized
by category so I'll always say so I'll
say I was genius I was preceded by a
college professor and here's what he
said and this guy is I known for pro
stocks attitudes and he said if you are
of average risk tolerance you should
have 85% of your money in this time know
if you're a below average risk tolerance
85 average risk times 105 if you're
aggressive 125 percent of your net worth
should be in the stock market and I just
think that most people can't live in the
long run in the short run with the
consequences of being that much invested
and and and being human we are our own
worst enemy everything that goes on in
the world and the market conspires to
make people buy when things are going
well and prices are high and sell when
things are going badly and prices are
low and and fighting that is the number
one theme of the book and it's the
number one theme of of success just from
personal experience and I mentioned this
earlier but looking at my response in
say 2008 I'd bought a house in 2007 with
some very unfortunate mortgage terms and
made some very bad decisions also with
money that I had in the stock market at
that time and I think in part it was
because I
I couldn't have known how I would
respond under those circumstances and
when I filled out this very
templated form of course for whoever it
was at the time I won't mention any
anyone by name but it was to what extent
would you be comfortable with a drop in
your portfolio over one quarter or one
year whatever the the form of the
question wasn't had 10% 20% 30% I
thought but 30% maybe I mean pulling an
answer out of thin air had to answer it
to get through the online form but I had
never experienced anything similar to
that and this just came to mind because
I'm looking at a book at a book on your
shelf bringing down the house about
games we were talking about games
earlier as I understand it bill gates I
think also Buffett played a fair amount
of bridge certainly many people in the
investing world including some people
are really really really fantastic some
of the guys from Renaissance and so on
poker then you have backgammon what do
you play and what do you think the game
that they select says about the person
if anything and could playing those
games help someone to assess their risk
tolerance for larger types of investing
or there are other ways to in any way
accurately determine that I think
accurately determine yes quantify no hmm
but I think that we can get a handle on
our degree of risk tolerance risk
aversion and we should and you know I
was with the my son and one of his
friends this week and his friend is a
great chess player the interesting thing
about people who play chess is that in
chess there's no randomness you know
there's no dice to roll there's no wind
to blow no card to pick from the deck
and and every all the information is on
the board and everybody has all the
information so it tells you something
about an intellectual process and you
know all the way out to craps which
where everything's you know in play all
the time based on randomness so maybe
which game we like tells us something
about ourselves but how we
a also tells us about ourselves
backgammon which is one of my main games
which is highly probability intensive
because it's all the dice it's the dice
and the skill but the dice mean a lot
you know in in any situation with any
throw of the dice there are aggressive
and defensive ways to play so you know
probably the interesting thing is that
if you played and I watched you for a
couple hours I would know if you're
aggressive or defensive or risk-averse
or risk tolerant and and and you should
be able to do the same for yourself the
one of the as I said before one of the
great things is to understand ourselves
and and without that we're really in
trouble what are some of the things that
otherwise smart people miss about cycles
or misconceptions that they believe to
be true like you said with Mark Twain
that just ain't so I think that well the
the biggest mistake you can make is
ignore the repetitive nature of the
cyclical pattern Ray Dalio and is in his
book principles talks about how much
analysis he and his partners did the
conclusion of which is the ability to
look at what's going on in the world or
in the market and say oh that's another
one of those life becomes very easy when
you have studied the past of the extent
that you've seen the recurring patterns
and you can recognize them when they
come up again so so I think that's I
think that's extremely important but the
other thing is and I think the guiding
quote of the book is is another one from
Mark Twain history does not repeat but
it does rhyme history does not repeat
the cycles are neither the same in terms
of amplitude speed duration cause or
ramifications but they do there are
themes that repeat that can help us to
identify and
properly respond to cyclical occurrences
so I say in the book that you know I've
been in the high-yield bond business now
40 years and there was a time when there
arose a body of thought that most
defaults occur on bonds second
anniversary since issuance and I don't I
don't think there was anything magical
about the second anniversary and you
know if people believed that then they
would sell all the bonds they had that
were 23 years 23 months old and buy him
back when there were 25 months old if
they had survived but I don't think they
would accomplish anything by that
because they were I think they were they
were assigning an import to a number
that was not valid so I think it's
really important to recognize cycles and
understand them
I think it's unimportant to assign
importance to these numbers or rules but
it's very important to understand what's
going on around us and when when when
the recovery is old the bull market is
old the psychology is elevated the the
valuations are high then you should know
that the odds are not on your side and
you should take some money off the table
and behave in a more cautious way and
vice versa so I suppose also on some
level necessitates cultivating a fair
degree of patience I mean it would seem
to me hey shion's is patience is
essential there was an investment sage
named Peter Bernstein and he said the
market is not an accommodating machine
who will not give you high returns
because you need or want them and you
know if I believe that right now we're
living in a low return world and if you
say Howard I need high returns in a low
return world the only way to try to get
them is by taking a lot of risk and by
definition taking a lot of risk is is
not sure to work and could
negative consequences so I believe that
when you're in a low return world you
have to accept it and deal accordingly
now this comes from mojo which we
started the interview with I talked
about mojo in a memo about 20 years ago
entitled it is what it is I think one of
the most important things that we can do
as adults be it be it in the investment
world or the real world is to say it is
what it is in other words accept things
for what they are deal with them as they
are don't spend a lot of time wishing
they were different you know certainly
don't act as if they were different we
have to accept the realities I've not
that in my in my little tiny corner of
investing which is I mean not even worth
mentioning really in this conversation
but I only bring it up to tie it to how
helpful actually reading certain I'm not
gonna it's not quite Scripture but
Buddhist thinking related to concepts
like mojo and stoic philosophy epictetus
and so on how helpful that has been to
tempering emotional reactivity you
mentioned someone I want to come back to
for a second Peter is it Bernstein nurse
Stein or Dean Bernstein financial
historian sadly passed away I think it
was in 2009 it I've read that you
consider him one of the smartest people
you've ever met why is that are there
any other things that you learned from
him forty-eight years ago when I was a
junior analyst following Xerox for
Citibank and I would give the portfolio
matters at the bank my opinions when um
came up to me and said who is the best
analyst on Wall Street on Xerox and I
said well the one who agrees with me the
most is so-and-so we always think that
the people who agree with us are really
smart and Peter saw the world the way I
did but in many cases put it into words
better and I wrote a memo called risk
no.6
risk revisited in
14 and then bizarrely one day I found
the memo from him you pay you mentioned
he passed away in Oneida in in 16 I
found a memo for him on my desk my desk
is a little messy and there's a lot of
stuff floating around and it was a great
memo entitled can risk be reduced to a
number and I took a bunch of stuff from
that in a redo of my memo entitled risk
revisited again but I just I just think
that Bernstein is great and and and in
on the subject of risk he said every day
we walk into the unknown and and as I
said the you know the future is a
distribution of possibilities and some
days we don't even know what the
possibilities are and and I conclude if
I can borrow your copy of the book yeah
I conclude with with a quote from him
because I think it's so good and if I
can find it quickly he said the future
is not ours to know but it helps to know
that being wrong is inevitable and
normal not some terrible tragedy not
some awful failing and reasoning not
even bad luck in most instances being
wrong comes with the franchise of an
activity whose outcome depends on an
unknown future and I think that that's a
great way to to think about the world we
have to work in and if you accept and
inhale the unpredictability variability
and randomness of the world I think
you're likely to do a lot better in it
now that doesn't mean you can't invest
you can't invest even boldly what it
means is you have to assume that things
are not going to always work out right
away well of course they're not always
going to work out but they're certainly
not always going to work out right away
which means what you have to
patience yes the same parry after the
fortitude you have to not invest so much
that if it goes against your gonna panic
and get out preparing for an unknown
world unpredictable maybe even hostile
world in the short run is probably a lot
smarter than assuming everything's gonna
go right and it's gonna go the way you
expected and it's going to go that way
right away and you're not going to be
tested and so I think that the this is
the kind of thinking that that that you
know when I read Bernstein or or some of
the other people I've mentioned you know
I just go oh yeah right sure that that
gets it for me you know and that's why I
love his stuff so much Warren Buffett
has mentioned how fond he is of your
writing and that and I'm paraphrasing
here but if he sees it in his inbox or
he sees one of your letters it's one of
the first things or the first thing
that'll pick up to read I'd love to ask
you about your reading
are there any say three to five specific
newsletters or colonists or Economist's
or writers who you find yourself excited
to read these days anyone who comes to
mind I I think the best you know I
worked mainly in the credit area not the
stock market so you know most people
invest mainly in the stock market and
and we've talked a lot about the stock
market but that's not what I do
professionally and our oak trees
investing is largely in in something
called credit which means fixed income
securities bonds and notes and loans not
issued by governments that's the
definition of credit and in our world I
think that is a great newsletter called
grants interest rate observer it's a
little ironic because it grants has
nothing to do with interest rates or
almost nothing but it's about credit and
and and in particular it exposes
stupidity and it exposes companies which
seem to be where people are not bringing
enough
scepticism and and deals that seem
unwise and that kind of thing and and I
think they do a great job now it I I
think it's fair to say that it has a
negative cast in other words they're
mainly talking about things with our
whitter which are rated higher than they
should be which you should avoid or bet
against I don't think they as often talk
about the things that are rated lower
than they should be and and and present
profit opportunities but for credit guys
like us avoiding the losers is extremely
important and and I think that's a great
a great newsletter not only for the
content but for the attitude and the
importance of identifying misperceptions
you know misperception is the key to
operating in the in the markets and the
variant perception you understand things
differently from the way everybody else
understands them is the key to success
assuming you're right if you understand
everything just the way everybody else
does clearly you can outperform that's
the death knell for a would-be
professional investor so you have to
have you have to see things different
from others that's a necessary condition
for our performance but you also have to
see it better than others that's
necessary to that the two the
combination of those two is what I call
second level thinking which which I
mentioned a couple times
you also mentioned how widely read
Charlie Munger is and certainly in poor
Charlie's Almanac for instance he talks
quite a bit about if I'm not missing
miss roaming evolutionary biology and
and really is able to pull concepts from
seemingly unrelated disciplines into his
power zone of investing and I've had
investors recommend certain books it's
are much broader than investing such as
lessons of history by will and Ariel
Durant which I found really fascinating
also I mean talks about cycles in a way
are there any books that you found
recommending a lot or that you've
enjoyed in the last few years that are
not specific to investing not specific
yes my my reading is usually closer in
that Charlie's so an example is the book
I'm working on now which is called fact
fulness and basically it it it unmasks a
lot of misperceptions that people have
about the state of the world and they
hold these perceptions generally
qualitatively not based on data and the
author tries to substitute facts for
these perceptions he starts with a list
of 13 questions describing the state of
the world and fascinatingly the I guess
he it gives you the answer to one and
you have to think about the answer the
other 12 the average score on the 12 is
2 and he points out that if you flip the
coin you'd get 6 right so the average
American gets two of the twelve
questions right and so not only are they
systematically wrong but they're wrong
in the same direction which is they
always pick the more pessimistic answer
when the more optimistic one is true and
so he's he responds to our bias and he
tries to overcome the ignorance and the
bias by using facts and and and some
great very communicative graphics so I
would recommend in fact fulness and I
love the idea of unmasking biases you
mentioned that and if I get this wrong
as I'm restating please correct me but
that in a low-yield environment to get
high yield entails increased risk I know
you've written a little bit about
cryptocurrency before the last I saw was
about I think I think from about a year
ago what is your what is your current
view or thoughts on cryptocurrency
if any that's one place that people are
going often with no understanding of the
technology or anything else I mean it
scares me enough although anyway I won't
get into my view on that stuff but
people who are well outside of tech well
outside of all that getting very very
bullish as it relates to cryptocurrency
but what are your thoughts I am what is
called a value investor and that means
you look at the situation you don't look
at the atmospherics you don't look at
the aesthetics you look at the value
hard value the the company's assets and
the cash flow that is business producers
and you value those things and you come
to something called the intrinsic value
and then you see if you can buy it for
less if you pay full intrinsic value
you'll probably get a fair return if you
pay more you'll probably have an
unsuccessful experience but if you can
buy it for less than the intrinsic value
you should have an above-average return
that's value investing and I think it is
the intellectually sound this form of
investing and nobody has been able to
tell me the intrinsic value of a Bitcoin
I believe there are assets in this world
where you can come up to intrinsic value
and they are the ones that produce cash
flow companies stocks bonds buildings
that kind of thing there are a lot of
assets in this world that do not produce
cash flow you cannot put an intrinsic
value on oil gold diamonds paintings
Bitcoin does it apply to all currencies
yes it does yes it does we cannot say
how many pounds a dollar is worth we
people look at them in terms of what's
called purchasing power parity but it
doesn't really work very well and the
truth of the matter is that
these macro considerations the
directions of economies and and markets
and currencies and commodity prices I
mean what's the intrinsic value of an
orange you know these things I think
can't be predicted reliably and in fact
the so called macro funds have been
doing quite poorly for years so there
are some things that can be valued and
some things that can and I believe that
bitcoin is one of the ones that can't be
valued and everybody says to me but you
don't understand and I wrote about this
in my July 17 memo and and and return to
it in in September I learned something
between July and September that's why I
put it in the next memo two people said
you just don't understand people are
gonna want a currency that the
government can't deflate and that can't
be counterfeited and can't be stolen and
all these things and so that's why I
returned to it but I still don't
understand how it can be valued I don't
in today a Bitcoin is sixty five hundred
dollars here on August the 10th and I
don't see how you can say it's worth
seventy five hundred or fifty five
hundred or anything like that you could
say it's going to be useful in the
future you can say people want a
currency a non-governmental currency but
I don't see how you can put a value on
it and and with all of its attractions
to the extent that people find
attractions in it last year it went from
one thousand to nineteen thousand now I
could be wrong but that tells me it's
speculative buying and by the way the
people who remember what I said about
people who have opinions believe in
their right obviously the people who it
traded at nineteen thousand somebody
thought it was a good buy at nineteen
thousand because it was going higher and
today it's a third of that so for the
most part reasonably valued value
investments do not go up 19 times in a
year and then down by two-thirds or are
there any understanding that you are
value investor
you mentioned a few other names and the
introduction your book Joel Greenblatt
who I'm also a fan of are there any
growth investors venture investors who
are there's certainly a person things
differently but are there are there any
particular growth or venture investors
or people who are playing a slightly
different approach who you have a lot of
respect for or admire for particular
reasons sure let me say there are many
ways to invest there are many people who
engage in activities that I think can't
be done and there are many people in
each one who do very well so you know I
don't I don't say mine is the only way
mm-hmm adventure is an example and I'm
not a futurist I'm not a dreamer I'm not
highly risk tolerant I'm not biased to
risk-taking and if if 40 years ago when
Citibank said to me they wanted me to
start a high-yield bond portfolio if
instead they would have said I want you
to start a venture capital fund I
probably would have been a disaster but
in the venture field you know the the
the firm's that success seems to be
recovering not random you know if if
let's say 20 percent 10 percent of
venture capital funds are successful you
would think that any given farm 20
percent of their funds would be
successful but there are firms which are
repeatedly successful you know I was
lucky in the last year to get to meet
Bill Gurley of benchmark and Bill was
nice enough to give me a blurb for the
jacket in my book and and I was very
impressed by our conversation and by
benchmarks record of achievement and
Sequoia has a great record and you know
kleiner perkins etc so you can do it but
it wouldn't be right for me that doesn't
mean it's not right for them the macro
there are there you know
I said 15 minutes ago that Mackrell
funds have had a pretty bad record some
of the greatest investors in history
have been macro investors George Soros
and and Stan Druckenmiller for example
have been fabulous they probably have
the highest returns of everybody and
quantitative investing Renaissance and
so forth so again it would be a terrible
form of hubris to say my up my way is
the only way my way is the way way that
works for me and by the way if you look
at the others
the success ratio is not terribly high
but certainly there are people who've
done it great yeah there's a very high
concentration of success and a handful
right at least within venture that bills
a very smart guy and all the firms you
mentioned have done really really well
so that I've heard said this is not not
from not from you in these words I don't
think but that you know the right
decision at the wrong time is the wrong
decision and I'm I'm very excited about
the new book and the literacy of cycles
that you are helping people to do
develop with this and we're gonna wrap
up in just a few questions are there any
particular mental models or heuristics
that are in this book or that you've
used in your investing life do you think
are particularly valuable kind of across
the board in life I know that's a big
question and you probably have quite a
few different directions you could go
with that but just in terms of becoming
a clearer thinker a better operating
human being does this does anything come
to mind that we haven't discussed so far
as it relates to any type of mental
model that would be worth mentioning
before we wrap up well you know Tim when
I finished writing the book and I was
thinking about cycles I said to myself
so for example the economy grows about
two two and a half percent a year on
average why doesn't it just grow
% every year why is it sometimes four
and sometimes one and sometimes five and
sometimes negative and the answer is
excesses and their correction and people
get too excited and they over expand
their businesses or they invest too much
or they invest too much using debt and
then something goes wrong and and that
and their excesses produce booms and
then something goes wrong and those
excessive activities turn out to be
unsustainable and they are then
corrected by selling off inventory
closing plans or or liquidating a
leveraged portfolio and those produce
busts so excesses and their correction
and I think the best thing that people
can do is be on the lookout for those
things and when other people are
engaging in excesses to the upside we
should turn cautious and when other
people are over correcting to the
downside we should turn aggressive and
and and I think you know it's been a big
part of what Bruce and I have
accomplished for the oaktree investors
and my other partners and colleagues too
and and it's something that everybody
can do if they if they turn their mind
to it well Howard I really appreciate
the time today good this is uh this is
this is very fun for me and hopefully
and I believe will be valuable for
people listening just to mention a few
things of course people can find
mastering the market cycle subtitle
getting the odds on your side everywhere
books are sold
you can also learn more at mastering the
market cycle calm people can learn more
about oak tree at oak tree capital calm
and on social media you have Twitter
Facebook and LinkedIn all the same
Howard Marks book so anything else that
you would like to say to the people
listening any recommendation question
they should ponder action you might ask
them to take anything at all besides
besides the book itself which I
encourage people to check out well first
of all we've made repeated reference to
my memos there
available online at oaktree capital comm
under the heading of insights Chairman's
memos you can get the last 29 years
worth you can also sign up for a service
that will notify you when one is
published the price is right because
they're free and and I hope people will
will read them and and and I just want
to say that I like to hear from people
so I don't always have time to answer
everybody but my writing of the memos
and the books has been enormous ly
rewarding because I get lovely memos
from people would say that I made
complex things seem clear that's the one
that gets me going the most so if people
want to comment or if they want to take
issue or or ask a question I'll try to
get back to them and this is the best
way to reach out to send you a note on
social media or I would advise against
giving out any type of email address
that will get deluged but or maybe the
answer is they should figure it out well
we're on social media okay and we'd be
glad to hear from there perfect why
thank you again so much for the time and
for everybody listening links to
everything we discussed will be in the
show notes as usual at tim blog forward
slash podcast and until next time thank
you for listening hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday event
provides a little morsel of fun for the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read
and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it this episode
is brought to you by helix sleep last
year I focused on dramatically improving
a few things surprise surprise
most it'll be the quality of my sleep
which seems to affect just about
everything this led me to revisit you
name it my daily routine morning routine
exercise diet all the way to what I
slept on and I ended up getting all new
beds here in Austin Texas including
mattresses from helix sleep helix has
built a slick quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleeper cold sleeper you like plush
you like firm with helix there's no more
guessing or confusion just go to helix
sleep calm forward-slash Tim take their
two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life that is their
promise for couples helix commitments to
flip the mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
fuel preferences for each side they have
a 10 year warranty and you can test
drive your mattress for 100 nights
risk-free right now helix is offering up
to 125 dollars off of all mattress
orders check it out get up to 125 off at
helix sleep comm forward slash Tim
that's helix sleep comm forward slash
Tim for 125 dollars off your mattress
order tickle ik helix sleep calm hold
slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by Inc
tel use them personally ever since I
wrote the 4-hour workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate pasts how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life and use that an
investing as well
the second how can I spend a little
money or moderate money to save
significant time Intel is one of those
investments they're a turnkey solution
for all of your imaginable customer care
units
I used a tel during the launch of the
4-hour body which was very very involved
and they provided 24/7 customer service
for my land rush campaign because it was
critical for me to take care of every
person who purchased my books and
participated this allowed me to focus on
the things that I am better at my
strengths like the marketing plan that
we've worked on for six months
implemented in the back intel trains
their experience customer service reps
to know your business and your products
inside and out and make your customers
raving fans they answer more than a
million customer service requests every
year and they can do so across all
platforms living email phone social
media text and chat leaving your
customers with poor service or just
mediocre service which by the way in a
competitive pool is a huge liability
long wait times or unanswered messages
carries a massive cost and risk to your
business Intel removes the logistics
headaches of this type of communication
allowing you to focus on your strengths
and grow your business it can be a real
competitive advantage and I see many
many e-commerce companies and tech
companies thinking of customer service
as a good enough check box or an
afterthought
and just like Airbnb you design and
innovative ways to be a competitor and
to win that you can do same thing with
customer service so as a listener of
this podcast you can get up to $10,000
off big discount $10,000 off your
startup fees and costs by visiting Inc
Telkom forward slash Tim so check it out
more info go to intel.com
i NK t PL comm 4/10
you